hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation titled mammalian
rnai response to virus infection this
webinar is part of the 2021 microbiology
virtual week and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots so
let's get started before we begin i want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
as a reminder the presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr shoe wade
dean a distinguished professor in the
department of microbiology and plant
pathology at the institute of
integrative genome biology at the
university of california riverside for a
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr bing welcome you may now
begin your presentation
hello everyone
my name is
joey dean and i am a professor
in the department
of microbiology and plant pathology
with university of california and
riverside
and the title of my talk today is
momenting rni response
to virus infection
a lot is known
about antiviral immunity in mammals
in fact the entire world
is using the knowledge gained from
biology and immunological
research
to
get us out of the current kovi 19
pandemic hopefully soon
and
entire viral
defense mechanism
in mammal can be
divided
into
adaptive immunity
in that immunity
okay
so adaptive immunity is mediated by b
cells and t cells
it has specificity and memory
however
adaptive immunity takes time to activate
innate immunity
contrast
can refer
broadly to all the mechanisms that
provide protection before the activation
of a depth immunity
it immediately includes
those
that initiated by
pattern recognition receptors
such as polite
receptor regai receptor c gas and so on
and in a immunity mechanism often depend
on the production
and the signaling
of interference
leading to
the induction of interference stimulated
genes
to activate
a broad spectrum antiviral state
today
i'm going to
present
recent fundings from my lab and
collaborators
on a distinct mammalian antiviral
defense
mechanism that is directed by
iron interference or rnai
i'm sure
all of you know about rna-i
and it includes
two key steps dicing
and slicing
so in the first step long double student
rna is diced
by
endo
ribonuclease dicer
into small interfering
rnas or srnas
in the second step
these srnas are loaded into
rna induced silencing complex or risk
in which argonaut protein is an
essential component
srna
are a product of dicer inline
and it's a
kind of very special
form of rna molecules
and that is
actually a shot due on a duplex
with five prime
phosphates
and two nucleotide
overhang
at each end of the three priming
okay so
rni pathways
actually direct
antiviral immunity
implants fungi nematode
and insects
for example
in fruit flies
viral double-stranded rna replicative
intermediate
are processed into virus-derived
srne of these rnas
by dice2
and these vs rnas are then loaded into
algo2 risk
to mediate
algo2 dependent virus clearance to
suppress viral
replication okay
to counter
defense
successful viral infection
depends on a viral
suppressor of ionize
expressed by the viral genome
so these viral suppressor of the rni or
vsr is essential for
infection
okay
so
oh i in um
floor house files what i have listed
here or fhv is a positive stand
rna virus
was the first animal virus
shown to induce
argo 2 dependent antiviral rna
in drosophila cells and also the first
virus to show
shown to encode a viral suppressor of
rna and that is the b2 protein
so studies
on
fluorescence infection
in fruit flies
provide
the
most of the knowledge
on what we know about antiviral rni
in fruit flies
and also these studies define how
the floccus virus b2 protein
to suppress ii
as a double-stranded rna bonding protein
to sequester
long-double-standing rna and prevent
dicer processing
into srmas
in
2016
we published a joint
paper
with professor k jeffrey's lab providing
the first example
for a human virus
to induce and suppress antiviral iron
eye in melanin cells
best
studies
influenza a virus
influenza a virus needs no introduction
i just to mention that these viruses
contain a segmented negative strain on
your genome
the reason why
we one of the main reasons
why we
chose to work on
in front of us
is because in
2004
we have published a paper
showing that the non-structured protein
one of influenza a values
is a suppressor
of anti-lateral rni in glossophila cells
so
to maximize
detection of rni response
we infected human cells
with
a ns1 deletion mutant of influenza a
virus the pr8 strain timely
provided by dr adolfo garcia sastry
these slides
[Music]
the top panel of this slide
shows the knowledge and blood detection
of viral srnas
from
monkey viral cells and human 293t
and
a549 cells
infected by the
ns1 delete mutant influenza a virus
okay
deep sequencing
of the smiling a total smartness from uh
human a549 cells infected by the ns1
deletion mutant
virus show
that
these cells accumulate abundant positive
strength and negative strength
influenza viral
srne
and these
influenza viral asylum gates are mostly
as you can see
22 nucleotides
long
and
contain
mainly when used species so when you
referring to those smart rnas
that have five prime terminal
u
as the uh the first nucleon the u s the
five prime terminal nucleotides and that
is a known property of endogenous
micronutrients
importantly
these
most of the sequence 22
nuclear anti-viral
simulant
form
the
canonical srna duplexes
with
220
nuclear type asparagus region in the
central
and two nucleotide
overhang at both
three plant main so indicating that
influenza viral exile
are processed by daiso
from the viral
double-stranded rna
replicative intermediate
however the influenza
viral srnas
were undetectable in all of the three
cell lines
after infection with
white type influenza a virus expressing
the
ns1 protein
so indicating that expression of ns1
protein inhibited
the production of viral srna
so what i have shown in this lens 3
6 and 9
blocks by a blue line
we
further sequenced
small rnas
in the arthronaut complex
immuno precipitated by a antibody
specific to all of the four human
argonaut protein
so showing
at the left
of this panel
are
total smart and a sequence from the
argument complexes so as you can see
these
complexes contain
mainly 21 to 23
nucleotides viral srna and highly
enriched for
1u22 nucleotide species
see uh similarly sequencing uh
the
cells
infected by a dna uh
ns1 deletion mutant of another strain
called wsn strain they're both h1n1
serotype
also find highly abundant
21 to 23
nucleotide viral srna in agonized
complex
put that compared to argo loaded
population
at the left
the
total small rna
sequencing
libraries contain
less dominant
22 nucleotides
vaporization however showing at the
bottom panel
to look for
canonical
srna duplexes with two nucleotide
overhang this is a minus two peak
indicating that even though the size
distribution
is not
uh
as obvious as for the argo load
population
these 22
nucleotides influenza viral srma
do form these canonical
sr multiplexes
so indicating that uh
selective loading
of 2122
nucleotide viral sr into argonaute
protein
so together
our results show
that
in the absence of a ns1
expression
infection with ns
with
influenza avails
does trigger production of highly
abundant viral srnas
and they are loaded into argonaute
complex
we have also shown that expression of
the ns1 protein
inhibits the production
of
influenza
viral srn
we also shown
in this paper but not shown
today
is that
using
the
dicer knockout
to
293 t cells kindly provided by brian
collins lab
we have shown that influenza viral
silent production
is
baser dependent
unfortunately
we find these dyson knockout cells are
not very useful for essaying
the anti-inflammatory
activity of the rnai
probably because those cells
do not make
most of the cellular
micrornas
and it is
perhaps for this reason
the jeffree lab focused on
argo 2 catalystic dead or ago to cd
cells mouse embryonic
fiber blood cells okay
so
just some
background that human or all mammals
encode
four
argonal protein and only argo 2 retains
rna slicing activity
essential
for rni
by synthetic srna you know so in ironi
knock knock-knock experiment you require
the argo 2 slicing activity to achieve
the
knockdown
of your target ml
and also shown by greg helen's lab that
mouse argo 2
with a single nucleotide mutation a
single amino acid mutation
d597a substitution is sufficient to
abolish
the slicing activity
however
those
maps
fibroblasts
were either y-type or carry instead as
catalytic dead algo2
uh
contains similar overall microrna
population so this is very different
from the 293t dyson knockout cells
so using these y-type
and
mutant
mouse embryonic fibroblasts
dr
jeffrey's lab
compared the infection
of
ns1 delete mutant
influenza aapia strain
showing in this slide
by real-time pcr analysis
you can see
the
mutant virus
replicated to
significantly higher levels
the catalytic dead cells
compared to y-type cells
using
each of the three
moi the inoculation concentrations
so indicating
that our goal 2 slicing activity
is
anti-viral against the influenza a
mutant virus
and the y-type influenza is also
replicated to
significantly higher
levels in the
algo2 catalytic dead cells
compared to
the y type cells
however the increases
were not as
dramatic
for the wide eye virus as for the ns1
deletion mutant shown in a slide
previously
so this suggests that
ns1 suppression
is not complete so the antiviral
the argo 2 slicing
slicing activity is still antiviral
against the y type in front of us even
though
the iron i suppress the protein and is
when is present
and
measuring the
production of infectious influenza a
virus particle by flood assay also
verified the enhanced eyes accumulation
in argo to cd cells compared to
whitehead cells
notably
slicer activity of argo2 does not appear
to play a role in an interferon response
because
the levels
of type 1 interferons and the induction
of inferion stimulated gene were similar
between white type and algo2cd cells
following either
iv infection
or
following infection or stimulation with
multiple viruses or viral like it
so
indicating that slicing
activity of our of argo 2 is antiviral
most likely by a hanging eye
but not by influencing the interferon
response
so
this slide summarize the first set of
data
i have
presented on the rni response to
influenza available infection
i have shown that infection
of monkey and human cells
with influenza a virus deficient in the
expression of the suppressor in s1
trigger
abundant
production of abundant viral srnas and
those as are loaded into argonaute to
mediate
suppression of virus accumulation
in a manner dependent on the argo-2
slicer activity
we have also
provided evidence that viral
the ns1 protein of influenza a virus
has
vital suppressor of rnai activity
however
many questions
remain open about the function and
mechanism
of
the mammalian rni response to virus
infection
for example
is dicer dependent production of viral
srna required for the antiviral defense
secondly are viral srma produced during
the
an active rni response
capable of guiding sequence specific rna
cleavage by argo2
thus interferon sickening inhibits the
production or the antiviral activity of
viral srnas
as suggested by studies
to induce an eye using artificial lung
double-stranded rna
and also we are not very clear about the
mechanism of viral suppressors of rna
and most importantly
is the
rni response active in vivo
we have addressed most of these
questions
in a mouse model of infection by noto
mirrors
so
normal mirror virus or nov
is not a human pathogen
but it causes lethal disease in
sickening mice
and can be transmitted by mosquitoes
aegypti it is egyptite so it is an i
support bone
virus
nodomira virus contain a small positive
strand
iron adrenal
divided into two segments
and encode only three functional
proteins in total
the caffeine protein precursor is
encoded and translated from rna2
ionian1 encodes two functional proteins
i depended on polymers and b2
from two partially overlapping reading
frame so b2 and rdrp
are not encoded in the same reading
frame
okay
so the rdrp is translated directly from
rna1
but b2 is translated from i3
which is a sub genomic rna of rna1
and after produced after replication of
ion when
so i should also mention that
because
on a one encode
rdrp
these rna can self replicate
replicate in the absence of irony too
and the main reason why
we have chosen
lunar mirror virus as our model is
because this virus belongs to the same
alpha nodal virus genus as the flow has
virus a virus we have used extensively
in our characterization of the fruit fly
end of our ironing response
so we know a lot about
uh how flight cells respond to the
infection
uh
by in flood customers
and
these virus
we have shown for follicles b2 protein
is a viral suppressor of iron eye
essential for infection
by inhibiting
dicer processing of viral lung double
strength
into srne
by sequestering
the
double-stranded rna precursor
moreover
in
2004
paper
published by my lab
jointly with
dr peter palesi and dr adobo
garcia
we have shown
that
no v
replication
induces argo to dependent antiviral rni
in both drosophila cell
and mosquito cells
and we have shown that
an node
encoded b2 protein is an active vsr in
insect cells
and most importantly
we have shown that in spite of only 19
percent sequence identity between the
two
b2 proteins
the conserved arginine
at position 54 of
uh and 59 of the flowerhouse virus
another mirror
virus b2 protein respectively
is essential for their vsr activity
to suppress either dicing diesel
processing in vitro
or antiviral rni into software cells
so remember this
single amino acids change at 59
amino acids of
non-mirror virus b2 will knock out its
activity
to suppressing dicing or on high into
supple cells
okay
so in
2013 we reported the first evidence
to show that notomira virus infection
induces and suppresses the rni response
in circuiting mice
so this slide
shows
that white had noto mirror virus
accumulated to very high levels
in the infected cycling rights
so the fold of amplification is over one
thousand
and by day five post inauguration all of
the infected
mice died such in my sight
so hundred percent mortality
by five dpi
we rescued
uh
a delta
b2 mutant virus using the
reverse genetic system
kindly provided by dr andy ball
and these delta b2 mutant virus
contain
three
single nucleotide substitutions
that prevent the translation of b2
without
altering the encoded
sequence of the overlapping of the
encoded rdip
in the overlapping reading frame so
these three nucleotide mutations
prevents
translation of b2 but has
had no additional effect
on the protein
of the rdrp
what we find that is
these delta v2 mutant virus
successfully
infected the second image
by spreading
from the inoculated
abdominal cavity
to the lymph tissues so
what i have shown here in a slight uh
real-time pci measurement of viral rna
accumulation
in full and high length tissues
as you can see the
delta b2 virus replicate to the
peak level
at day three post inoculation
but then drop
quickly
and start from 4 dpi and
and
7 dpi that basically the virus delta v2
virus level was about 1 000 for less
compared to
the type values infection
and so most importantly all of the mice
inoculated by delta b2 values remain
healthy
throughout the duration of
the experiment
so indicating that
lots of b2 protein
abolish the
virulence
of the mutant virus
we further
rescued
another mutant virus
by
introducing
a single amino acid
r2q mutation at position
59 of b2
so this virus we called
nb2 meter numbers
and again the mutation will not
impact
the rdip sequence encoded in the
overlapping reading frame
so as you can see
these
mb2 mutant virus behave very similarly
to the delta b2 mutant virus it
replicates a
spread
and and accumulate to high level by
day three
but then start to drop
to day four and day seven is as low as
the delta v2 meter max
so together
these results
show
that the b2's
vsr activity not just the expression the
vsr activity because the mb2
mutant matters actually express b2
protein but it's not active
vsr
so indicating the vsr activity of b2 is
essential for
mouse infection and variance
so sequencing the
total smart
from delta b2 mutant virus infected such
invites revealed production of
an approximately
equal ratio of positive strength and
negative strength viral srnes
these viral srn are predominantly 22
nucleotides long and enriched
for the canonical srn duplexes
indicating that non-neural viral srna
are processed
by dicer from the viral dsi replicative
intermediate
however
carnal canonical viral srnas when
undetectable in cyclin lights infected
by
the y-type nodular mirror device showing
that
delta b2 various clearance in vivo was
accompanied
by
production of highly abundant viruses
and these srne are not visible
during lethal infection by y-type
monomials
so in a recent
paper published jointly with young lee's
lab in plus pathogen
we compared
the population of viral sin is
sequenced
without
with or without
adenoco-immuno precipitation
so as you can see
that
these
viral
neuromural viral srne accumulate to very
high level in argonaut
complexes showing at the bottom panel
and they are mainly 21 to 23 nucleotides
long
and
predominantly at 22
and
when you uh
srna is very
abundant
mapping of the viral sign into the
genome further revealed high densities
of srne
targeting the five prime terminal
regions of iron a1 and rna2 as well as
the ionis 3 encoding region of rna
2
1
and if you compare the pattern of the
hot spot distribution you will find the
total smartening and argo
ip rna are very similar so suggesting
that loading
into argenon
is proportionally for the viral srn
produced in the mice
however
we
find
a highly abundant
canonical viral srnes in the b2 immuno
precipitates
compared to the total
without b2 code immune
immunoprecipitation you can see the
uh in the b2 complexes
they are abundant
particularly the 22 nuclear
rna that form these minus two kind of
population so the one that has
20 nucleotides spared region with two
nucleotides three parameter overhead
so
however if you look
in the argo ap
population
low abundant
uh in the wide high values infected
circumstances so indicating
that
b2
binding of duplex srna
and
but these
b2 binding prevent the duplex rna to be
loaded into argonaut okay so
there is a second function for the b2
shown by this set of data that b2
bind to smiling duplex and prevent
loading
into
risk conflicts
however this study also showed that b2
suppression of dicer processing is not
complete
so there is actually some
srn aids are produced
but not loaded into argument
so
uh we recently investigated the genetics
of iron eye response against neuromura
virus in mouse embryonic
fibroblasts
because dicer and argo not how mice are
not liable so we are using
this system to
investigate the genetic
requirement of antiviral io
so this slide shows the northern blood
analysis of the nodule mirror large iron
in one self-replication in y-type cells
and we find that white have cells
support efficient
self-replication of viral genomic rna-1
and the subsequent transcription of the
sub-genomic rna-3
however both rna-1 and rna-3 were barely
detectable
uh following self-replication of delta
b2 mutant rna1 indicating an essential
role for b2 in rna viral ionic
accumulation
notably we find both rna1 and i3 of the
delta v2 meter91 accumulated to high
levels in both dicer and argo 2 knockout
cells showing in the middle of this
panel
and as well as
rescue in the
cells
expressing a catalytic dead
argo 2 or argo cd maps
so
these
we further measure
the virus rna levels
in those
y-type and mutant
maps using real-time pcr
what you can see
and the very left two
bars
showing the significant
higher accumulation of rna1
uh
for the y-type ion when versus the
delta v2 only one
however
both
uh
y-type and delta b2 are when replicated
to significantly high level in all of
the three rna high defective
lines of cells
so indicating that b2 enhances
viral ionic accumulation only by
suppressing ioni
and b2 becomes
not active at all
when an eye response is abolished
moreover
in spite of b2 expression
y-type rna1
replicated to significantly higher
levels in rna high defective cells
than
whitehead cells
indicating that compared to knocking out
dicer or argo to slicing activity b2
suppression of an eye
is not complete it's partial
so
this is a very important point so even
during y type b2 expression ini is not
completely suppressed
we also measured
ice g
levels expressing expression
in those y type and mutant
cells
before and after infection and we find
that b2 expression
has
no
obvious effect on the induction
of interferon stimulated genes in either
y type or uni defective lines of
maps
so further supporting the conclusion
that b2 enhances light accumulation only
by
eye suppression not by
influencing the
other interferon regulated responses
we
also sequenced uh small ionics from
y-type and
dysonator argo 2 nautical or argo2cv
cells
after
replication of delta b2
rna1
as you can see here their
production of viral srna many 22
nucleotide long in the wide half cells
and highly abundant
in
algo2 not out and now go to ct cells
but not at all in daiso knockout cells
so these indicate that
production
of
viral ethane is
iso-dependent and algo2
is not required for viral sign
production that is required for the
activity of these srns
however
if we uh we sequence
the uh
total smile from white have only one
replicated cells and we find only
very low abundant viral srna in
a white heightened ago to
knock out an algorithm cd cells so
indicating that b2 suppress production
suppresses the production of viral signs
so we have recently
developed an adult mouse model of
infection
for a
nodal neural virus infection using
regular knockout strain of mice that are
defective in adaptive immunity because
it do not
they do not produce mature t-cell b
cells
and
intact
in
interferon antiviral responses
so
we find that uh
unlike the y-type c 57
black
6
mice adele mice
that are highly resistant to another
miramar infection the red one
knockout
knives
are highly susceptible to novi infection
and most of the
adult mice
infected by nobody died
so
indicating
this
adaptive immunity confers resistance
in adult mates
however
none of
neither of these
mutant virus
delta b2 or
mutant b2 virus
are able to cause any visible disease
in
the regular knockout mice and the
infected
viruses are rapidly cleared
so
indicating that
lethal infection
of regulan adoptments require b2's
vsi activity
and so sequencing the small rna
from the regular infected mice
shows that infection by either mutant
virus induce abundant viral srna and
they are loading into argo2
but not in
adult mice infected by y-type non-mirror
virus
so
these results show
that antiviral protection by rni
is not inhibited by active signaling of
interference in a
regular domain
so
the
we further compared
uh y type and mutant virus infection in
step one and step two double knockout
mice these mice
are completely defective in in sickening
by all three types of interference
we find that
wide type narrow mirror virus cause
litho infection but both of the
methanols are defective
defective in
eye suppression cause no disease and are
cleared very rapidly
as shown
by
real-time pcr analyses
so these results show
that
a functional b2 protein is required for
lethal infection of adult mice
defective in innate antiviral responses
regulated by type 1 2 and 3 interference
further supporting the conclusion that
b2 acts to suppress antiviral rni to
promote infection
but not the interferon regulated
antibiotic responses
so as expected
uh
in the infection with either virus
uh induced expression of isgs and
independent beta genes
uh in the y type and regulator mice but
not instead when two double knockout
mice
and so
these
indicate that um
that b2 expression does not suppress the
invisible
interferon responses in adult males
so the next question is
[Music]
whether the viral hazard produced in the
adele mice are actually
active
in
directing
rna slicing
so
we are
developing a system
to
ask that question
so you may remember that because
uh infected mice produce
highly overlapping set of viral srna so
it's very difficult if not impossible to
map
wrist slicing inside the infected cell
to overcome that problem we synthesize
artificial rna target
that contain in this case a t1 rna 20 42
nucleotide
single stranded contain a central region
that is perfectly best fitted with a
viral enzyme known to be present in algo
complexes
so
the predict slicing of this target rna
will produce
a 22
nucleotide five prime
cleaved product
so if we label the phi prime n we will
be able to detect this
cleavage product in a page analysis
as a negative control we
uh
we synthesize
uh a mutant
t1 rna with only one nucleotide mutation
from the t1 so this mutation would
disrupt best pairing
at the tense nucleotide position
[Music]
known
to
abolish
si directed slicing
and as a positive control
we synthesize a t2 target rna that is
perfectly best paired with a micron a 22
also
accumulated
in the algo complexes so this is a mouse
endogenous nikon
so
we
then you know infected mice with delta
v2 virus
and use the antibody to
argument
to
prepare
purified argonaut complexes and then
incubate these complexes with the t1 rna
or t2 rna so shown here is a page
analysis
showing the detection of the cleavage
product of t1
after incubating with argo
complexes
prepared from
the delta v2 virus infected
regulators
so there is a very efficient cleavage
however
we
did not detect cleavage
using the control igg
complex immuno precipitated from the
same infected mice
we also do not see cleavage using
argonaut complexes purified from
uninfected regular knockout mice
and all marked by the blue
boxes
so
we
then
test the cleavage of the mutant t1 ia
we find using the same algo complexes
purify from there there be two
virus infected regular mice we do not
see cleavage of
mutant t1
that differ only by one nucleotide so
indicating that
the cleavage
was highly specific
and induced
by
infection
with the delta v2 mutant mass
subsequently
we also
compared
the t
cleavage of t2
target rna so this is the one that
targeted by micro rna
and you can see the
in the marked by blue
red boxes
argonaut complexes
prepared from either mug mice mock
inoculate mice or delta b2 infected mice
you see cleavage
very similar efficient cleavage
so
indicating that
micro diuretic cleavage
is not induced or suppressed by viral
infection
okay
and
these micron a t2 cleavage
was not detected if we use the control
igg so indicating the cleavage is
mediated by angle 2
okay
so
then we compared um
argonaut uh
uh
argo2 uh rna slicing
by
you know guided by a viral enzyme or
microrna
from um
red one or step one step two nautical
mice
so as you can see
that the cleavage of
t2 rna directed by micron 22 is
similarly efficient
uh in
regular mice or steroids that two double
knockout mice whether or not they are
infected or not
so micro iron cleavage is not
influenced or altered
by infection
or not infection or whether by a
presence or a active interferon
sickening or the complete defective
interference signal
so
in contrast
uh
the there we see
cleavage
of the t1 rna by viral sr only
in virus infected mice
okay however
we see a cleavage
of the t1 rna
in both regular mice and step ones that
two knock out mics although the step one
step two not colonized
the algal complexes appear to be less
efficient
so this suggests that blocking
interferon sickening instead of instead
of two knockout mice
does not enhance
production of slicing components based
on argo-2 complexes
this is a very different from
the studies using artificial non-double
strong rna to induce rnai okay so
we then compared a slicing
diagonal complexes purify from regular
and knockout mice or stepwise that too
uh
no this is different okay
so um
pardon me so this slides actually
compare
algo slicing
in
regular mice infected by normal mirror
virus or mutant virus
as you can see from the two uh
lens on the
right
that infection by either methanols
trigger very efficient slicing of t1 rna
but
the slicing
of t1 rna is very weak in a wide high
virus infected mice and you have to
have a longer exposure to see the
cleavage band
so indicating that b2 expression
blocked or suppressed the production of
slicing competent
viral
algo2 complexes
we also do the same comparison
instead when step two narcotics again
you see
infection with either mutant virus
triggered
slicing of t1 rna
but not in a
wild highlights
infected step one starting knockout mics
so
indicating that b2
expression
[Music]
inhibits the individual production of
viral and a slicing component argo 2
risk
in adult mice
in
either
completely defective or intact in
interval signaling
and i think this is one of the final
data
last data slides
this is
compared
expression uh slicing
of
micro rna
in the
normal mirror that is infected or mutant
there had to be two infected mice and so
showing that
in contrast to
antiviral
slicing
microrna
directed slicing was similar using the
algo complexes purified from adobe mice
following infection
with
y-type or mutant virus
so indicating that
expression of the b2 does not interfere
with the function of the cellular
microarray so very in contrast to the
antiviral silencing
so this is a summary
um
that
um
what i have shown uh on the
study of a mice model infection
by non-mural virus we use uh y-type and
rni defective
mouse embryonic fibroblasts we use
succulent mice we use at all mice either
intact or completely defective in
interval signaling
and so we provided five lines of every
evidence
to support induction of antiviral ionic
response
by
nodal mineral viral infection
first we show that in response to
neuromural viral infection
differentiated mouse embryonic
fibroblasts
cyclinine and adult mice produce
abundant
risk-loaded rsrna
from dicer processing of viral
dsn replicative inhibitors and these rna
are loaded in
argonaute
direct specific slicing so these viral
sr loaded argonauts are active to
direct
specific irony slicing
and there's a lot of activity are not
affected by
presence or absence of
interferon sickening
uh we show uh
inhibition of rna
virus
accumulation by antiviral rni in a
pathway require
both dice immediate production of our
srna and rna slicing activity of argo 2.
and we have shown that
neural mirror virus uh
encode uh uh
suppressor protein b2
uh essential for infection in cells and
secondary mice and atomize and there are
two
mechanism to suppress
rni
suppress dicing processing processing or
suppress argonaut loading
most importantly we find v2
only
promote viral infection only by
suppressing ionia
not by
any other mean because b2 become
inactive
in rni defective
cells
and the b2 suppression is incomplete
and finally
we show that uh
iii response
when the b2
is inactive or
absent
uh the ii response confer complete
antiviral protection in and almost
either intact or defective in
interference regulated interference uh
in that immunity
so this is what i have shown in my lab
but there is also uh
additional
human rna viruses have been shown by
others to encode
uh double-stranded binding suppressors
of iron saline
rnai
and this includes the protein b2
um
um
from the pecan of everyday and flurry
very day and chrono video and hungary
day
and the recent studies by uh
juicy's lab shown that
vsr knockout
mutant
hgb71 or dengue
dengue 2
uh induced ii in differentiated cell and
mice
okay
and i have to wrap up um
why thai virus can also induce uh ioi
and we
it's known for quite some time now uh
infection of iron differentiated cells
by wide virus or mutant mass can induce
ii
and the recent paper published by
cateno
rasa saucers lab shown
a novel dicer isoform
in stem cells confer essential roles in
antibiotics
so
this is the last slide showing that uh
there is an additional form
of antiviral iron immunity in mammals
directed by
rni and these
response acts only like
and initiated by dicer processing of
viral dsi and replicative intermediates
similar to inner immunity however it has
specificity mechanism and this mechanism
is different from the adept immunity
because the specificity is programmed by
viral srna so finally i'd like to thank
the past and present members of my lab
and also
for their contribution to the mammalian
eye response projects
we started in 2009 in the lab
and i also like to thank my
collaborators
uh
our studies on in neuromural virus and
influenza environs started
with a collaboration with andy ball and
also and peter
more than 16 years ago and
our collaboration with jeffrey started
uh
from a
seminar visit to boston in 2015
and also i'd like to
thank the funding provided by national
institute of health
and i finally thank you for your
attention
bye-bye
i will be looking forward
to
answering questions
by email